[Musica]
quando ha ricevuto l'invito per questo
talk
ho avuto dei sentimenti contrastanti
da una parte vedevo l'opportunità di
dire la mia su un tema ancora così poco
intavolato in maniera critica
dall'informazione e dai media ma
dall'altra sentivo un certo disagio un
peso nell'avere l'onere e l'onore di
raccontare la storia di qualcun altro
così non sentendomi in grado di
raccontare qualcosa che non avevo mai
vissuto sulla mia pelle ho pensato
perché invece non parlare di qualcosa
che io vivo attivamente tutti i giorni
così ho pensato di parlare di privilegio
in quanto appunto lo agisco
ma cos'è il privilegio bianco
spesso facciamo fatica ad accorgersene
perché è molto più difficile riconoscere
di avere un vantaggio gratuito se lo si
adopera e lo si agisce
ma esiste una discriminazione e
sistemica
sotto forma di forza invisibile capace
di infettare ogni singolo angolo della
società
e dico sistemica perché questi sono
fatti più vecchi del capitalismo che le
alimenta
come descrivere una
violenza
implicita ed invisibile
come spiegare un vantaggio sottointeso e
mai esplicito
qualcuno direbbe che bianco e neutro che
normalità che bianco e di default
ma spesso chi ne parla in questi termini
e non è un caso ne parla in quanto
appartenente appartenenti a minoranze
etniche in quanto discriminato in una
società dove bianchezza e purezza
e mi viene da pensare
ma allora noi bianchi né bianche in
tutto ciò
ai quali il privilegio a fare così
affabilità non rendersene nemmeno conto
abbiamo una responsabilità
una responsabilità che va oltre il
semplice e nemmeno tanto semplice
diventare consapevoli ma appunto
interiorizzare la forte connessione che
esiste tra il nostro colore della pelle
e le agevolazioni che ne comporta nella
società e non fermarci alla mera
esistenza
di questa constatazione
dobbiamo metterci un po il dito nella
piaga no
perché laddove qualcuno si avvale di un
privilegio c'è qualcun altro che ne
subisce una discriminazione
e non inganniamoci pensando che esistano
delle soluzioni facili e pronte all'uso
che semplicemente rendendoci conto del
privilegio questo scompaia nel nulla e
si è risolto il problema
perché non basteranno non basterà la
consapevolezza a cancellare centinaia
d'anni di schiavitù di ghettizzazioni e
di discriminazioni ingiustificate
non viviamo in una società post razziale
crederlo significherebbe vivere in una
bolla di comfort
allora serve dialogo critico
serve
svelare il privilegio e metterci faccia
a faccia con il problema per sentire il
disagio di essere dei privilegiati
e proprio perché non abbiamo delle
soluzioni ma abbiamo un privilegio
dobbiamo usarlo attivamente al massimo
per ridurlo al minimo
non sto dicendo che la vita di tutte le
persone bianche sia facile questo deve
essere chiaro proprio perché è una
persona può essere discriminata e
privilegiata ma su due ambiti diversi
possiamo essere bianchi ma poveri
possiamo essere bianchi e madonne ma
appena si parla di privilegio nella sua
assolutezza e nelle sue sfaccettature
è come se ci scende se la cataratta un
velo sopra l'organismo e non siamo più
in grado di sentire e percepire
gli infimi particolari di una storia
ingiusta
spesso non c'è proprio la volontà di
interiorizzarlo perché sappiamo in fondo
di essere dalla parte del torto
riconosciamo la presenza di
atteggiamenti di condizioni agiate e
meno agiate per colpa di atteggiamenti
societari razzisti ma quasi mai
mettiamo in discussione il fatto che
questo sia un vantaggio che derivi da
una storia coloniale e che abbia posto
le basi per una società nella quale il
bianco è considerato normale a discapito
di tutto il resto
non mi è ancora convinti beh nel 1492 e
nessuno ma proprio nessuno
nemmeno quelli che ci abitavano
conosceva l'america per fortuna poi è
arrivato un genovese più furbo di tutti
oggi infatti tutti sappiamo dove
l'america ma quanti di noi possono dire
di conoscere un nativo americano
e questo è soltanto un esempio degli
innumerevoli delle innumerevoli stragi
che abbiamo messo sul piedistallo invece
che condannato e che fanno parte di
quell insieme di barbarie che oggi fanno
da cornice al nostro privilegio
è che anche se non ci siamo mai resi
responsabili di razzismo attivo facciamo
comunque parte
di quella fascia consapevole e
implicitamente complice in quanto go
denti di un privilegio a priori
una frase che forse
potrebbe diciamo riassumere il concetto
è quando diciamo di essere nati nel lato
fortunato del mondo
ma fortunato o sfruttatore
trasliamo adesso la questione del
privilegio su un altro ambito per
capirci meglio
su ad esempio il privilegio che ha un
uomo rispetto a una donna
ma allora entriamo un attimo più nel
particolare e
attenzioni amo un attimo il gap
esistente tra un uomo bianco occidentale
e una donna migrante climatica africana
un divario in termini di opportunità e
possibilità immenso
secondo una ricerca del parlamento
europeo
il genere femminile risente molto di più
delle conseguenze della crisi climatica
le donne infatti sono ancora molto
spesso associate al lavoro di cura
le donne si caricano del lavoro del del
benessere della famiglia e degli altri
molto spesso mettendo in secondo piano
la la loro stessa vita
e con l'aumento delle temperature con la
siccità con gli eventi estremi
aumenta anche il la diffusione delle
malattie e quindi aumenta il carico di
lavoro per le donne e il rischio di
ammalarsi
senza considerare poi che donne e
ragazze migranti sono più vulnerabili
a violenze sessuali e molto spesso le
loro condizioni sanitarie e delle loro
esigenze sanitarie non vengono
rispettate
allora che il rompere lo schema del
privilegio
non si fermi soltanto alla dialettica ma
che tenti insistentemente tutti i giorni
di annullarlo nella pratica per
permetterne ea per permettere a tutte e
tutti di goderne o per annullarlo e
basta insomma come vi pare
perché spezzare le catene del della
discriminazione
significa non subirne più in alcun modo
significa radicare un sistema di soprusi
significa non girarsi più dall'altra
parte e soprattutto
significa spezzare quei meccanismi che
ci portano ad essere rabbiosi e
insoddisfatti e che non fanno altro che
generare rabbia e insoddisfazione
io questa via d'uscita dal privilegio la
sto cercando e la cerco tutti i giorni
e dato che il privilegio non è uno
soltanto ma uno spettro di categorie di
dominazione abbiamo bisogno di un
ventaglio di vie d'uscita
io per il momento ho trovato una
confortevole
rassicurante piccola dimensione
una via d'uscita che si chiama attivismo
cinque minuti fa mi hanno presentata in
in maniera eccellente ma ci terrei a
rifarlo in prima persona
piacere sono michela ho 25 anni e oltre
un sacco di casini nella vita faccio
anche attivismo per il clima
e quando dico per il clima
intendo per la giustizia climatica e
sociale intendo per l'abolizione dello
sfruttamento umano e animale
per la sicurezza alimentare per un
futuro delle prossime generazioni e
un'infinita serie di cose bellissime lo
giuro
viene da sé che
slegare la crisi climatica al concetto
di privilegio ha poco senso
se è vero che lo sfruttamento sfrenato
delle risorse è stato adoperato dai
paesi occidentali nel sud del mondo e
che queste azioni ci stanno portando al
collasso climatico
è vero anche che per invertire la rotta
bisogna unire i puntini e slegarsi dalla
concezione che per difendere il clima
bisogni bisogna badare solamente
all'ambiente
ecco invece la visione contorta che
abbiamo noi occidentali c'è una foresta
defoe restiamo c'è una miniera
espropriamo ci sono dei minerali
espropriamo e facciamo una miniera
oppure c'è una riserva naturale
trasformiamola in un safari per la
caccia sequestrando la savana i popoli
indigeni a colpi d'arma da fuoco e
questo sta succedendo in questo momento
in tanzania
e se tutto ciò invece succedesse a casa
nostra sotto i nostri occhi
lo troveremo inaccettabile
faremo di tutto per non perdere
la facoltà di decidere della nostra vita
e soprattutto lo saprebbe tutto il mondo
ma dato che queste cose molto spesso
succedono in luoghi dimenticati
dall'immaginario collettivo
automaticamente ci viene da importarci
né meno
e non è forse un privilegio questo
perché l'essere
riconosciuti sulle cartine geografiche
essere riconosciuti nelle foto le tre
mete turistiche fa la differenza
e lo dico perché in quanto a posti
dimenticati da dio io qualcosina ne so
sì ho dimenticato di dirvi che vengo dal
molise
non esiste il molise quello del ama
quindi una regione scusa molin sam
provinciali che facciamo noi
un posto che la mia stessa nazione ha
dimenticato e abbandonato all'incuria
perché questo modello di sviluppo non va
dalla vocazione del territorio ma
omologa e globalizza per eliminare la
diversità oppure emargina e trascura
quando non riesce o non ha tempo per
farlo
e dico questo perché avere un identità
geografica significa sapere che esiste
nel mondo e che come tutte e tutti
hai il diritto di di viverci in maniera
dignitosa che rispetti i diritti umani
fondamentali dell'uomo
mi mi rendo conto di star parlando di
cose enormi ma so anche che il mondo non
cambierà mai se non mi attivo
effettivamente per cambiarlo
e con questo non intendo che il mio
scopo nella vita è quello di arrivare
alla perfetta vita di un attivista
ineccepibile
ma anzi rendermi conto che non potrò mai
esserlo se continuo
se il mondo continua ad essere
ad essere alimentato da prevaricazione e
prepotenza
e la via d'uscita di cui vi parlavo
prima vuole proprio di staccarsi da
questo tipo di schemi che ci stanno
portando al collasso climatico
e io so di poter fare qualcosa in più in
quanto dispongo di un privilegio e sono
libera di usarlo quando dove come voglio
ed è proprio questo che io vi chiedo
oggi
perché se io da sola non posso cambiare
il mondo ma il mondo può ancora cambiare
questa visione distorta che si porta da
troppo tempo
sono convinta che la coscienza
collettiva e l'attivismo siano l'arma
più potente e inutilizzata che l'umanità
abbia mai avuto a disposizione e sono
anche molto curiosa di sapere che piega
prenderà la storia quando decideremo di
usarle davvero grazie
[Applauso]